i will not learn about crypto from
abroad just shut up misogynist good
thing he's banned goddamn male purpose
good thing he's banned
andrew tate full time kickboxing world
champion top g you know the guy i think
we've watched him a couple of chill tree
times you guys grandma called me today
and told me that she knows him and she's
into it grandma's into tate yeah she's
82. she wanted me to tell tate that i
get it what he's doing that she gets it
like i think she thinks i know take
grandma probably sees the split screen
and thanks for like zoom with him or
something yeah take grandma says hi
she's 82. she's got a rye on you all
right tate actually got banned from all
social media platforms within the last
like three days the other day first
instagram and facebook he's already been
banned on twitter and now youtube just
deleted his channel the censorship is
here they deleted his whole channel why
because it doesn't fit their agenda they
say he's like inciting violence i've
seen so much inflammatory inflammatory
[ __ ] on youtube but if it's left-leaning
it's fine if it's right-leaning it's
censored censorship is the death of
america if we get there where free
speech is limited they're not even
hiding that they're trying to censor
people anymore they're not even hiding
what they censor you're literally it's
going to become a hell hole on social
media soon take my word for it you're
going to want to blow yourself you're
going to want to blow your head off
every time you go on instagram and see
these these stupid girl stories well all
the people that uh for the last two
years have done nothing for their
country or the causes they think about
they've gone back into their selfish
little worlds are gonna start putting up
you know black squares and rainbow flags
and [ __ ] on their on their social media
to act like they care if they cared they
would dedicate their lives to and
actually do something for it one you
know a lot of them showed up to some
protests oh big deal what do you think
that really did go get a law degree and
change laws if you really think that you
want to make a difference you know what
it's both that they're banning tate
let's go back to the original point free
speech the fact that an american company
is banning free speech is a disgrace so
this girl that he knows made a truth
about her um her experience with him and
it's going viral so i wanted to react to
it with you let's do it i want to tell
you who he is based on my personal
experiences with him we did an interview
together which has actually got 2.1
million views so if you haven't seen
that i'm gonna leave the card for you
here and also links again in the
description below so definitely check
that out i've actually met andrew on
several occasions the first time i met
him was in 2020 so two years ago we met
in romania in bucharest they're a mutual
friend and we all went out for dinner
together he turned up in a lambo which
was pretty cool um he was there with his
girlfriend i was there with some friends
and we all had dinner and we all had a
really really nice time we spoke a lot
about crypto we spoke a lot about covid
we spoke a lot about all the crazy
things that are going on in the world at
the moment he asked me my opinion on it
we had a really nice intellectual
conversation he wasn't rude to me he
wasn't inappropriate with me and he was
very gentlemanly and very friendly we
then ordered some food he said please
order anything you like he was very
polite and friendly to the waiters and
waitresses which i think is also a sign
of somebody's character that's part of
being a man that a lot of these people
don't even understand with what he's
saying too is you need to be a gentleman
when you go to a like a
a restaurant with a girl tip the guy
tipped people be up be a cheat typical
closest tip to hostess
big shout out to some bills no and it's
it really is it's also great really
lovely for the people who are working
but yeah and i don't know why a lot of
people are starting to think like being
a real man is like being a [ __ ] to
everybody it's not it's being like very
respectful to other people pretty much
at all times actually it's like being
extra generous and kind and sweet and
calm and under that is a badass who's
who only comes out when he needs to
that's what that is so i was with this
um
in college dating this guy and his
friend came to uh lunch with us and he
needed something from the waitress and
he was like this like snap into her i
was so mortified so mortified that after
we paid the check they went outside i
ran back in and gave her and this is
years ago where it was like you know big
deal i gave her another 10 bucks i was
like i'm so sorry about that please that
wasn't all of us that act like i am so
sorry hey baby come on man get over here
hey i need more dressing or whatever it
was like embarrassing awful rude that's
not being a man a man men have
manners and grace and they can kick the
living [ __ ] out of you only if needed
ordered wine meats starters dessert we
had a really great time a couple days
later we were actually invited to go
over to his house i got to his house and
he was very hospitable very friendly he
showed us around he was very respectful
and it felt uncomfortable he was very
nice very friendly he was very funny we
spoke a lot about bitcoin and crypto he
told me about different investments he
made i think in like link or something
like that and everybody was just
chatting having a really nice time we
ordered some drinks we ordered some food
he then went to go play chess on the
computer by himself and we just spoke
about everything and anything he wasn't
inappropriate with me he didn't try
touch me inappropriately or speak with
me inappropriately he just asked me
really about things that i'm interested
in you know and actually one story that
i do really want to recount is they'd
ordered some pizza for us him and his
brother had ordered some pizza i don't
eat pork ham or anything that comes from
a pig and so they ordered pizza with
pepperoni on it and sausages and stuff
like that so i turned around to him i
said hey do you mind i know you've
already ordered it but do you mind
calling the back and ordering something
else i can't eat that he was more than
happy to do that and i felt more than
comfortable asking called them back up
ordered me i'm a margarita pizza and it
was no problem there were some other
girls there they were all having a
really nice time everybody seemed really
happy and like they were enjoying
themselves it was then time to leave and
i got an uber home and that was it so
that was two years ago fast forward to
september 2021 we hadn't really spoken
but he actually dropped me a text
message saying that he was going to be
in london where i was based at the time
um do i want to come out and meet him
and just catch up so i actually went to
go meet andrew his brother and some of
their friends um in knightsbridge so i
went by myself i got an uber and i went
to go meet him i decided to go by myself
because i felt fully comfortable i
trusted this person i met him twice um
i've had conversations with him and i
trusted him he was very gentlemanly he
welcomed me i sat next to him we spoke a
lot about my book actually which he said
he was going to buy and he never did so
that's my only up to this point that's
my only bad thing maybe he just had his
assistant fire because he's not going to
do that [ __ ] himself wait her what her
book he said he was going to buy her
book she said he didn't i'm sure oh i
didn't even know she said i actually can
tell already by the tape brothers that
yeah i i would feel safe with them like
they don't have a weird rapey
vibe i can tell that they would be
classy and gentlemanly and kind if you
really listen to them talk you know that
that's like they're intelligent there's
probably great conversation at the table
my favorite part about entertaining fame
like popular now is seeing stuff that he
says and i've thought for a while or
that you've taught me about like being a
gentleman or business and mindset stuff
i'm like damn i already knew that that's
kind of it's kind of dope i'm already on
the same track you know what i mean
don't call me pumpkin sneakers the
pumpkin pumpkin's in the chat please
addressing bitcoin i'll leave the link
in the description but he hasn't bought
it yet but he said it's not buying your
bitcoin book lady so andrew you need to
buy my book you promised me i will not
learn about crypto from abroad just shut
up
we ordered every single he ordered every
single cocktail on the menu he ordered
me a cigar to smoke i never smoked a
cigar before and again we just spoke
about the world we spoke about the last
two years nobody was misogynistic nobody
made any uncomfortable jokes nobody
tried again to touch me inappropriately
or anything like that there's a reason
they get so many girls it's because
they're so respectful they're like that
and they're g's if you're a g and you're
respectful to girls they love it it's
not about being a dick it's about having
the other features of your life so much
better it it you don't even have to be a
g i've said this a thousand times for
the you know the people out there who
are never going to be a big old g be
respectful make a girl laugh be kind
open the door be a gentleman you don't
have money you don't need to have money
to have class and manners do you want
the kind of girl that likes being talked
to like [ __ ] is that who you want i know
that's not the kind of girl that i want
everything was very nice i felt very
comfortable and his brother had a nice
young girl that was there she seemed
very happy like she was enjoying herself
then eventually i decided that i wanted
to go home and andrew walked me out got
up like a gentleman brought me to the
front of the building and he ordered me
an uber home and he ordered me an xxl
executive the most over-the-top
extravagant uber there is he paid for it
and he said to the uber driver this is
my wife please make sure you look after
her make sure she gets home safely
otherwise he'd have him to deal with i
thought that was very very right that is
awesome being very gentle
safely which is totally different and in
contrast to what social media is saying
about him they're saying that he hates
women he abuses women and clearly none
of that is true in my personal
experience so far i've been with him
alone with his brothers and
nothing negative has happened i've
always felt very protected and very
comfortable and he texted me to make
sure that i got home okay andrew says
that women are the most precious things
on the planet and they need to be
protected misogynist good thing he's
banned goddamn male purple good thing
he's banned teaching men to be good to
women what's the matter with him
treat him like um i'm in miami he's in
miami and he drops me a message and he
says hey let's do an interview so i
actually got an uber to his place to his
house where he was staying in miami
again i went by myself and i felt very
comfortable to go by myself and i was
right i get to his place and then
andrew's just there around the corner
and he says hi and everything was very
nice um and actually he had this um he
had professional catering staff so
they'd actually laid out like a long
table in the kitchen of fruits there was
granola yogurts there was crack coffee
tea everything looked really delicious
um and he offered me some breakfast
which was nice we kind of discussed the
questions that we were going to talk
about now i wanted to do the interview
with him because he has a lot of
controversial opinions and there's a lot
that i agreed with him on in the
interview there's parts that i disagreed
with him on which i kind of mentioned
but overall i was very open-minded and
happy to do the interview because i
really wanted to learn more about him
okay so the first controversial comment
which a lot of people don't like that he
said in the interview was he compared
women to children now i think a lot of
what andrew says is hyperbole and i
think it's exaggerated and it's simply
just an analogy no he doesn't literally
think women are children women all day
long are like talking about their men
like their children they leave their
socks on the floor if they get a cold
they do nothing but cry oh my god i feel
like i'm his mother so when that when a
man does it it's it's misogyny and it's
you know let's raise hell over it but we
do it all day long like oh god this guy
pain in the ass i gotta clean up after
him i got to do everything for him he
can't even change a roll of toilet paper
he's like five we do that all day long
and it seems to be okay for women but
not for him to say it it's frustrating
it's like everybody calm down women are
not men women are delicate women are
emotional women need help whether it's
emotional support whether it's physical
support you know we need attention i it
doesn't diminish my womanhood to let
someone carry stuff for me take care of
a problem your dad was here last week he
he fixed the garbage disposal what would
i have proved by like i would figure
that out myself yeah i could have hired
somebody but he was here wanna do it and
it made him feel good to do it because
men like to do for women and anyone
that's gonna get mad about that [ __ ] why
are you wasting your time there's
children who are missing and the same
thing is that those
sex trafficked children
those same dumb broads that complain
about that stuff i mean that say that
stuff they complain when their men
doesn't do the masculine stuff he's
always writing poetry he never talks to
me
they're that anchor to reality which i
think women really need but like i said
you've got to take what he says with a
pinch of salt he's a marketer it's
hyperbole it's going to be exaggerated
okay the second point is the whole thing
about monogamy he says when you're a
high value man you can have as many
women as you want now i agree i don't
necessarily think this is ethical or
unethical but i think it's true you see
some of the mo the richest most
successful men in the world they have
multiple women because they can now
here's the distinction and the important
point to make if all the women involved
know the truth they know the deal they
know what's going on then i think it's
fine my pushback was he was sort of
saying that you know all men are this
way i don't think he can talk all men
with the same brush i think that would
be unfair this is exactly what i said
again that she says she says it really
in a way lovelier way with her beautiful
accent yeah she is
hello that is so she's lovely she really
is i said the same thing though it's not
even like about kate's talking about the
top point one percent of men anyways and
all men think that he's talking to them
when realistically he's not but when he
says
stop it put yourself together it's not
the top one percent of men it is eight
percent of men all men at the top don't
need to operate like tate people are
different and it so it's so so just get
that into your head he also says that
the majority of men if they had the
option to that's what they would want
and i would agree with that i would
agree that if a man is that high of a
level and he has his beautiful girl but
he could easily get
four others and bring him on we're gonna
go if you're super high value you're the
man that every single woman wants then
yes you can have multiple women and the
women will be okay with that there were
other things that i disagreed with him
on but overall it doesn't really matter
because at the end of the day we're
having a conversation and just because i
may disagree with him on something it
doesn't mean that i have to be offended
it doesn't mean that he's being sexist
it doesn't mean that he's being
misogynistic doesn't mean that he's
being an abuser it just means we
disagree where are these women why can't
there be girls my age like that i don't
know what [ __ ] you're following online
but i know i can see them all the time i
find little potential burn laws all day
long online
one of the most controversial things
that um keeps going around and a lot of
my friends are actually texting me
saying um is leia how can you justify
andrew's opinion whereby andrew says
women are my property now are women the
property of men it's a great question
now again i think that statement is
hyperbole i think that it's an
exaggeration of um a greater sentiment
essentially in that it's the man's
responsibility to provide for her to
lead her to protect her that's sort of
why he would say women are a man's
property you don't have to be offended
yeah just oh my god she doesn't miss my
frustration around the misconceptions
around hyperbole is through the roof i
get so frustrated with that and people
are going to be like oh trigger
triggered yeah i'm allowed to have some
feelings okay i love that when our
comments are like she was triggered am i
supposed to be monotone and not have
feelings about anything have i not said
i'm a broken italian girl jesus christ
anyway
hyperbole is just that and it's just
basically a fancy word for exaggeration
her being approached by her friends and
saying what do you mean about him saying
women are property he's just
exaggerating he's just saying these are
his these are things that matter to him
that he feels a sense of responsibility
for people are just the things that they
get caught on again just to go back to
your science go find a missing child
before you get caught up in all this
really put your energy into something
that matters go make some bills why the
father walks the woman down the aisle
when she gets married it's always going
to be a man that walks the woman down
the aisle and gives her over to her
husband since the dawn of time women
have been men's property but not in a
negative way in a way that is the man's
responsibility to always look after her
always provide for her always to make
sure she's okay she's safe i think
that's beautiful i think we're trying to
be offended by something which actually
is a very beautiful concept in fact the
kind of man that i'm looking for
is a man that will also consider me to
be his property because when i'm his
property he's gonna make sure nothing
bad happens to his property the same way
a man protects his car his house his
family is the same way that i hope that
my husband one day will protect me are
you going to protect her when you guys
get married because you're oh oh my god
she's having armed guards yeah i know
she's i'll be out there with the guards
if if you marry this girl i'll be like
you stay away from my lane
my princess leia a lot of these clips
that we see of andrew have actually been
taken out of context so when he talks
about younger girls we're not talking
about women who are younger than 18 and
i don't think he's ever said that i've
never heard andrew say he's into young
girls he's talking about women in their
20s as opposed to women in their 30s and
40s
who've been run through excuse me i hate
that expression but that's what he said
or you say or the the kids that's what
he said he said that um the older woman
gets she's more ran through and that's
why you attract that a younger woman i
think a lot of this stuff with andrew
he's saying what everybody else is
thinking men since the dawn of time have
preferred younger women for whatever
reason and that's okay women have always
dated older men nobody's ever had a
problem with that the kind of man that
i'm looking for is a man that's going to
be in his thirties because i'm in my
thirties i just wanted to get you out
like you're thirty i just wanted to get
that out there i'm in my thirties i
remember when i was growing up and i was
19 20 21 and i'd be wanting a man that
was 25 26 and the men my own age would
be really hurt and offended by that and
there's nothing you can do about that i
didn't like guys my own age the same way
men don't like women their own age they
date down women day up this is just
reality and it's not a big deal yeah
it's not a big deal but they want all
norms of society to crumble so that
everything as a whole can just can just
collapse well they also want everything
to be exactly how they think it should
be through their lens which is a
variation on killing free speech people
are they say that they're tolerant and
they want everybody to be unique and
independent but they don't they want
everybody to be exactly like they are
and it's so absurd like these people who
decide to think differently but aren't
hurting anybody or i'm breaking any laws
and we have really great rights in this
country and you know again
there are people around the country
around the world watching this who are
like oh this american [ __ ] has such a
small
lens and she doesn't know anything i'm
talking mostly about america what is
wrong with people having a different way
of life in a different perspective
nothing it's nothing it's there's
nothing wrong with what she's saying and
there's true and there's nothing wrong
with what these other people want if you
want to chop your dick off go chop your
dick off you want to be married to a man
as a man go do it i don't give a [ __ ]
but why is this getting censored why why
is like the the norms of society getting
censored and this new crazy [ __ ] is is
getting propagated it's a real bug out
the only sensor the right they don't
censor the alt left at all if anything
no one should be censored let everyone
rip their stoop run their stupid mouths
if something if if somebody is really
that bad don't you trust the american
people to make up their own minds the
answer to that is obviously no jew is
doing a great good for women and for
feminism i think andrew's actually the
greatest feminist if you think about it
and i've actually texted andrew and i
told him women girls that are 15 years
old um in 10 years time will have will
have a big thank you to say to andrew
because the guys that are currently 25
are consuming his content and learning
how to be a man you know what does it
mean to be a man what does it mean to
protect and provide forget toxic
masculinity andrew's actually teaching
men how to be men she's gonna love you
she's gonna love you oh i'm gonna treat
her right to wrap up i think there's a
massive war on masculinity right now to
really show this war and masculinity
across media outlets they're talking
about you know if a man wants to work
out and he's got muscles it means he's
he's a right wing and he's probably
going to be sexist and a misogynist the
left they were saying on social media
that if you don't want to sleep with the
trans woman that you're transphobic
i didn't hear comment comment if you
remember that because that happened that
was a good few months where i was in dms
arguing with people that if i don't want
to sleep with a [ __ ] dude then i'm
transphobic please comment if you saw
the same thing please because i i don't
want to be crazy if i saw that in a
dream or something no but it does sound
like something someone would say no i
don't know what i really appreciated
just on on that vein but it supports
your man your
belief around it tristan tate i was just
now i'm watching tate and tristan like
they just show up in my feed now yeah so
he was talking about lgbtq ai plus oh
yeah really hurts the lesbian and gay
community because for the majority
because they get lumped in with all this
other stuff men who transform into women
shouldn't be in women's sports if i say
that which i think you already know i
already believe that that means that
because they're all lumped together that
i'm also against lesbian and gay
lifestyles which is utter [ __ ] and
completely different because less mean
and gay lifestyles let's go have fun
you're good people you're normal you're
you know all of us you're not hurting
anybody you're in love you're good
friends to me i have wonderful friends
like give me a break that
that i can't be be completely fully
supportive of gay marriage and still
think that a man shouldn't compete in a
woman's sport no we gotta do that's
[ __ ] and you know what
i just wanna say say because it really
clarified it in a way that i was
struggling with the messaging on it that
lumping all of them together is another
political play to label people
homophobic and transphobic because i
disagree with this little sliver of it
that i hate all of it the government
this system they want you weak they want
men particular to be weak fat and
compliant so that they can't fight the
tyranny because when you're weak fat and
compliant i'm addicted to porn and
unable to get outside your house and
actually be aware of what's going on in
the world they want you to take your
antidepressants believe it's real rather
than going out to the gym trying to
better yourself they want you to be a
slave they want to control you that's
all they care about which is as old as
time that's what the problem is wake up
wake up men are intelligent when men are
entrepreneurs where men are hitting the
gym that is not good for those who are
in charge and so like i said earlier i'm
personally very excited about what
andrew's doing and he's empowering men
to be better as a woman i want a strong
man i want a man that's going to look
after me and only a strong man who knows
how to take personal responsibility
somebody that's wise somebody that's
smart only that kind of man is going to
be able to do that a lot of women are
settling for men that aren't
particularly strong because there aren't
strong men left and so women are
miserable women are then having to
become more masculine so they can fill
that void that's been created by society
because men aren't men anymore so
overall to wrap up this video i have had
nothing but positive encounters with
andrew tate he's always been very
gentlemanly i think he's very fun he's
very charismatic and he's very smart and
i think he's a great businessman he's
also let me say i haven't mentioned this
yet he's also loyal he's loyal to his
friends he's loyal to his brothers and
that is a huge sign of somebody's
character there's a lot of accusations
about him online and honestly i just
don't believe them because i've met the
guy and because i don't believe them i
will meet andrew again and we will do
another podcast again i am following her
all day
bam
done sonny's mother's behind you girl so
leia 34 with five mil generated at eight
um at 34. oh you're 34 now yes he's 34.
what the [ __ ] does that make me
anything let's give let's give leo a 1
to 10. yeah easy 10. come on let's let's
keep moving that was that was an easy
peasy thank you guys so much for
watching as always i'm giving a hundred
dollars to someone who likes subscribes
and joins my discord give your final
remarks say something funny come on
don't make me try to say something funny
it just happens naturally
[Music]
won't last long